save room for our love all right for
many parents navigating relationships
and adapting to a new normal can be a
challenge it's a topic we're discussing
this morning in our Vlad to Dad Series
where we help Vlad who is still here
with us prepare for fatherhood licensed
marriage and family therapist Dr George
James has some tips for couples on how
to embrace Parenthood while keeping the
relationship strong good morning Dr
James how are you doing good morning
glad to be here all right so how does
having a baby change the dynamic in a
relationship I mean you have a baby and
literally in moments your whole world
shifts it changes you go from excitement
and Euphoria to maybe sometimes a little
resentment and difficulty thinking about
parenting ways that you want a parent
and even if you think about me time that
does that goes off the table that's
right so like there's a lot that changes
nature said right away that's true
it's we time right right it's baby time
yeah that's a fact
um so it's it's interesting that you
point that out because I did have a
friend in France who once said to me
that when his child was born he was a
little resentful even though he loved
the baby loves the mom but the mother's
Focus was 100 on the child anything that
was going on between them before was not
happening and he was sort of like what
am I chopped liver so how do you
overcome those feelings so it happens
and I think it happens for a lot of dads
where they start to feel a little
jealous a little resentment some of it
is to recognize that the baby is going
to be front and center but that's why
communication is so important being able
to talk with each other and figure out a
game plan how are we going to stay
connected what are we going to do how
are we going to make sure we take care
of baby but also take care of the
relationship it's easier said than done
but it is possible to make sure that you
do that so what do you recommend what
are some steps parents can do before the
baby arrives because I'm glad you have I
got January 29th yes ah yes
what I would say first right is to make
sure you communicate have a plan and a
backup plan and what happens for a lot
of parents as you know is that once you
have a plan it goes right out the window
right as soon as the baby comes that
means who's how what are you going to do
at night who's going to feed who's going
to take turns if Mom's nursing are you
going to change the baby if if mom is
using formula are you going to use both
of you be able to to feed the baby find
out your plan ahead of time yeah and
when talking about that plan you
mentioned making time for each other
which is important it's not just uh on
an emotional level but of course on a
physical level too you know we talk
about keeping the relationship strong
also keeping it spicy that's right how
do you do that so there's two parts of
that I like to share with people
non-sexual intimacy which is around
connection sitting on the couch holding
hands doing those things huge make sure
you do that asking each other babe how
are you doing today are you okay and
then there's sexual intimacy which kind
of falls to the Wayside a little bit and
being able to communicate about that
because your body might be ready but
your emotions might not be you might be
fatigued overwhelmed so being able to
connect and say we will get there let's
find other ways to stay connected do you
believe men need to have more
sensitivity and maybe even information
and education on what a woman may be
going through after the baby I think
historically yes lots of men have
probably needed a little bit more
sensitivity in that area and what I
would say is it's okay to embrace all
your feelings right feel the feelings
right so you're going to feel enjoy
excitement Euphoria maybe you know hey
what about me right it's okay to express
that and be patient there's also a lot
of focus on the mother you know because
of course we're the ones going through
the physical part of this but but don't
forget that you're going through stuff
too and a dad to Adriana no it's true I
mean obviously the mother's a priority
yes and your wife is in the green room
but we also did our part too to help
with that's right that's that's true but
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
ups and downs with the dad as well and
so there might be highs and lows and
just just know that that's okay that's
great advice it is important to keep
that in mind because I I often think
that you know one of the pitfalls is
that we the we imagine well I'm not
involved in these discussions because
the woman is the one who went through
the the nine months and the pain of
delivery and so I'm just gonna stay out
of this and let her make all the
decisions but there's room for us too
there's so much room and what we've seen
is 50 more of dads say they're more
engaged they're saying that I love you
they're reading with their kids they're
more there more invade involved than
their fathers from before and if I could
say one last thing right okay here it is
talk to me we're out of time just
kidding yes and this comes from a real
Source Miss Sarah Green who recently
passed at the ripe wonderful age of 100
said don't be a lazy parent and that is
so important that means stay engaged be
involved be the dad you want to be and
also don't be a lazy partner be
connected to your spouse
Dr James thank you so much we will be
right back